dear kitten under my tutelage you seem
to have gotten the hang of this being a
kitten thing I've taught you well but
you may wonder how I became so
knowledgeable it may be hard to believe
but I too was once a tiny buffoon much
like yourself but cuter than you like
way cuter kind of ridiculous actually
when I was a kitten I lived in a wire
box with my brothers and one sister my
mama wasn't too keen on me being a cage
fighter but that didn't stop me from
training day and night my dream was to
one day take on the beetle that lived on
the other side of the room then drooly
faced knuckle head was always taunting
me
but that day would never come to
fruition
instead my family eventually left and
there's not a day that goes by that I
don't think about them except my sister
she was the worst
dear kitten they say that ignorant is
bliss but whoever they are must be
pretty dumb my own thirst for knowledge
was quite ravenous when I moved away
from home so many things to touch
pockets to nap in and things to fall off
of but unbeknownst to me I was being
observed
I've told you of Maximilian before rest
in peace I looked up to him quite
literally he was massive and always in
the places of op it wasn't until he took
me under his wing that I learned the
dark arts of karate I'm talking about
shadow boxing invisibility training and
even sneak attacks now that I think of
it he was actually kind of a jerk in the
end I did get the last laugh because
he's dead rest in peace and see I also
learned a lot from my friend Cornelius
he didn't say much but he did teach me
patience posture and how to stare for a
really long time without blinking he was
very good at it
like very good we had a good thing going
but not all friendships are meant to
last well I learned many things in those
early days but perhaps the most valuable
lesson of all is that the wet stuff is
the best stuff I came up with that the
first time it touched my lips I knew I
had chosen the right human do you know
what I'm talking about you chose her too
kitten did you get any of that Oh No
okay well fine I am going to hang out
with Richard missed a bunch of good
stuff
Oh